Okay, hello everybody, disconnect my phone here and we are live with another holistic health hour.
So let me get the chat ready. If you guys have chat questions, make sure you chat in the questions.
And as always, you always have the ability to go to holisticelthour.com.
And ask the questions prior to this time, which many of you already did.
So we have several questions to go over beforehand.
But I do know that in my other Zoom calls and presentations, as we are talking about different things, you think about different things.
So you are united about somebody in your life that has issues or you that may have issues that maybe you have a question.
So I know we are starting a couple of minutes early.
So give you a little bit more information.
Our connersclinic.com also, and I refer to this each time.
But make sure you go to that if you have questions as well, because I don't want you to have to wait till Wednesday to get your questions answered on cuttersclinic.com.
We have well over a thousand blog posts that may address the question that you have.
So go to that. We have a really nice search bar on cuttersclinic.
You can search for different questions on our blog post. We have lots of pages.
You know, probably 1500 different pages, if you include all our blog post pages.
Also on our YouTube channel and our old video channel dot cuttersclinic.com.
We have well over 1100 videos that you could search for different topics that you might be interested in.
It's quite possible that I made a video about it.
Again, holistichealthower.com is where you'd post questions.
And let's jump to some of those questions.
First one, my wife thinks that she may have a bladder infection.
She has to get up several times a night to urinate.
There is sometimes a fall order order.
She has paid or she has no paid or other symptoms.
What's a good supplement to take to help support her bladder health?
Thank you for your help.
So if you think that you have a bladder infection, so many times,
the first sign of a bladder infection is just increase your radiation.
A lot of times people with bladder infections have no paid.
And interesting to note, as people age, like in your 70s, 80s, 80 year old,
many times the only symptom to a bladder infection is abnormal thought patterns, abnormal behavior.
So in a geriatric population, you'll just see someone kind of out of it, kind of talking gibberish, talking like what's matter with this person.
First thing you need to suspect is a hidden UTI.
Many times they don't have any urinary issues.
As a younger person, urinary issues may be the first sign.
Different orders of the urine can be a sign that can be more a sign of Candida type issues, especially if it's an Eastie order.
But what would you do about it if you suspect it?
First of all, it's good to get a culture.
You could even get your old urinary dip sticks on Amazon.
And you could test whether you have bacteria in your urine or go to the doctor and get a UA to see if you have bacteria in the urine.
If you do have bacteria in the urine, they're going to recommend a culture, which would be the most appropriate thing.
Sometimes doctors will just reach for their pad and give out a prescription for an antibiotic.
If you're so inclined to not want to do antibiotics and want to do a natural approach, things like D-Mannos, which is a sugar, could be extremely helpful for urinary tract infections.
If you look at our store to get to our store, you can go to cuttersclinic.com, the upper right-hand corner of the website.
You'll see shop or store.
Click on that and you'll go to our store and you can search urinary tract infections or search D-Mannos, M-A-N-O-S-E.
We have several products that are high dose D-Mannos that are specifically for UTIs.
We also have specific products for Candida.
So if you search for Candida in the East infections, you'll see different products.
Because if it's a Candida, you do want to treat it a little bit differently.
D-Mannos can help with that as well, but treating it to rebalance the flora can be something you need to address as well.
Because Candida is an imbalance in the flora.
Usually it's not just affecting the UTI, it's usually affecting the gut and getting some balance in your microbiota can be beneficial.
The question comes in on the chat, Facebook user.
Can you explain what is having smooth muscle antibodies?
So when you have antibodies to self tissue, that's an autoimmune disease.
So smooth muscle antibodies, I don't know, I have to research that a little bit.
But any type of autoimmune disease means that you have antibodies to self tissue.
If you have antibodies to self tissue, then you're in a totally different ball of wax is how you should be treating yourself from a nutritional dietary protocol.
I'd highly recommend not that I just want to push a product, but I'd highly recommend you spend $50 and join our autoimmune course.
Because there's so once you have self antibodies, if you're going to be taking the immune stimulants because anytime you are.
So if you're any what naturally minded, you might be taking immune stimulants because especially during the recent COVID thing, a lot of people were taking immune stimulants.
If those people had self antibodies, many people found out that they had an autoimmune disease because that was a certain time of their life that they started taking a lot of immune stimulants and they felt worse.
If you have self antibodies, antibodies to self tissue, when you're going to take products that are immune direct immune stimulants, you're going to kill that which you have antibodies against first, which is going to be self tissue.
If you have antibodies to smooth muscle tissue, you're going to end up with problems, smooth muscles line your arteries, you're going to end up with issues with blood pressure, you're going to end up with, you know, so smooth muscles line other things too, but your biggest thing as far as symptom pattern is going to be arterial, so it's going to have blood pressure issues.
So if you want to be careful, that's why I highly suggest that people will have, you know, serious health issues that they run antibody tests.
So typically, if we do a case review, when a person has had health issues for a period of time, they've been to multiple doctors, nobody's ever done an antibody test.
We need to find out, do you have self antibodies because you could be completely treating this wrong.
Sometimes people will say, I think you have lines, so we're going to give you cats, claw, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And they're giving them these things and the person's continuing to get sick and the doctor will say, no, you're just having a hurt side of a reaction.
You need to work through this. This is a good thing. It's not a good thing.
So if you're stimulating immune system function and you have self antibodies, antibodies to your tissue, you're going to feel worse because you're going to have more destruction of whatever you have antibodies against.
So, you know, for the $50 to learn how to look at autoimmune disease the right way, it's a small investment.
Certainly you can do a case review with me too, but if you know that you have self antibodies, you know, you have an autoimmune disease, spend the 50 bucks on that course and start working through it.
You'll have a ton of moments and then you can make a case review with set up a case review with me and we can go over, you know, different possible treatment parameters.
Next question. I have MS and trigeminal neuralgia, which module is best seven stages, which course is best.
So I think that's what you're asking is the seventh phases of detox the best course. No, I would say chronic disease in autoimmune would be the best course because MS is an autoimmune disease.
So MS is you have antibodies to myelin sheath cells. So now you have an autoimmune destruction of your myelin sheath.
So MS is a D myelin 80 disease and the rate of demyelination is going to be dependent upon the rate of destruction and the rate of destruction is going to be dependent upon you getting a handle on.
What are the triggers in the immune destruction of the myelin sheath cells. So go back to what I just said about autoimmune disease.
You have antibodies to myelin sheath cells. You need to find out what's triggering your immune response. It could be what I just mentioned.
I'm taking a bunch of immune stimulants because my naturopath told me to take it or I read that this is good for it.
That's really absolutely the wrong thing to do. So we don't wait. Let's say another patient. I'm not taking any of that stuff. You know I'm not doing any of that stuff.
Well, if you're stimulating your immune system in another way, maybe like eating a food that you have antibodies against.
So let's say let's say you have antibodies against gluten and you're eating gluten. It's stimulating the immune upkick and you're destroying more myelin sheath cells.
So very destructive. So you got to find those triggers and I go through that in you know, I know I see a lot of core. So I think that would be the best course to say.
Tri geminal neuralgia is different. So tri geminal neuralgia is not a disease. So tri geminal neuralgia is an inflammation of the tri geminal nerve.
So the tri geminal nerve is your cranial nerve that controls part of the motor function of your face. It could be extremely painful.
There are many different causes to it. So it's not a disease that has a just one cause. There can be many different scenarios that can be, you know, has to do with inflammation from.
Again, from a secondary autoimmune disease like MS, you could have inflammation due to, you know, from a chiropractic issue with your cervical spine, you could have inflammation due to just a myriad of different things.
So digging to find out what the cause of that inflammation isn't calling that down is going to be key.
Over the years, I worked with multiple tri geminal neuralgia patients from a functional structural point of view, and we had great success.
So you want to address it from a structural point of view in a laboratory point of view, an autoimmune point of view, and you're going to have good success.
I would not suggest a detoxification course. I'd suggest that autoimmune course.
Any tips on PMR, not medical advice, but for an 83 year old patient.
Again, with PMR, you have to get to the cause of things. Like any disorder you have going on, you want to get to the cause of things. From a medical standpoint, with polymialgia, any polymialgia issues, they're typically just going to give you paid medication.
From a functional standpoint, it's many times looked at as a chronic inflammation issue, looking at blood work, you might find an increase in your inflammatory markers.
Typically, blood work that's done on these type of people is just going to be a CVC and a complete metabolic panel. This is where I advocate highly into looking at autoimmune panels too.
If you have antibodies to self tissue, that's going to be a huge issue that you want to deal with. So digging into deeper blood work is going to be the key to that.
That's really honestly the key to so many disorders. So many people are struggling with things that I hear are, I've been to multiple doctors and I don't know how to treat this. Nobody's gotten to the bottom of this.
Then you ask for that patient to send in all their labs, and it's amazing how few labs, many times, that people have, or all they've had done as a CVC in a complete metabolic panel through their GP.
And sometimes it's really disturbing because sometimes they even had gross abnormalities and that and nothing was investigated and nothing was moved forward.
Many times people would have overwhelming symptoms because they have an ademia, but then nobody ever addresses the ademia.
Back to another question on the Facebook page, any dietary changes for PMR just over, again, overall, there's some inflammatory process going on.
So a person would do much better going on an anti inflammatory diet. You could just Google an anti inflammatory diet that would help.
I would highly suspect though that there's specific dietary antibodies.
The common with this would be gluten, also possibly lectins could be an issue because you could actually have rheumatoid factor positive that would be the benefit of doing antibody test.
If R.A. is antibodies are present, then I would say lectins can be a big culprit.
So you could look up a lectin, a low lectin diet or a lectin free diet, certainly gluten free diet and just overall just an anti inflammatory diet.
And like anything, when you have an uptick of inflammation, systemic inflammation in the body, you always have to think that there's inflammation as a gut.
That's why food sensitivity panels, like a Cyrex array 10, would be the right choice in something like this because it's amazing what you could do when you calm down the gut, what you could do from a systemic standpoint.
We've had people with inflammatory arthritis, you know, they were diagnosed with psoriatic arthritis or rheumatoid arthritis.
It would just cleaned up the gut and did a Cyrex array 10, cleaned up the gut with diets, things that are causing inflammation of the gut and all their symptoms calm down.
And longer you have an arthritis like that, you have body changes, you're never going to change those body changes, but if you could decrease inflammation, you could decrease 95% of the patient's symptoms.
So like anything, you're always looking for the cause, you're always looking for the source. So you're going to be digging to that source.
And you know, it's not enough to say, oh, you have inflammation, your Cyrex approach is high, your fabric is high, you know, something like that, you want to, you want to go, okay, well, why is that, you know, what is the cause of that as well.
So digging to that is important.
Next question.
Remember holistic help hour.com where you can submit your questions.
Prior to this, so you make sure they're getting answered when we order.
I have a full body red light and infrared light therapy device, I have heard that mixing things.
Mixed things about using this when you have cancer, I currently have breast cancer, I'm also using a right machine.
What do you think about this? Thank you.
I don't think there's any problem with using red light therapy.
Infrared light therapy is just by two.
I will caution you that if you have an infrared light therapy that costs you less than $5,000,
it's probably got less than 1% really true infrared light.
And I don't mean to first anybody's bubble, but it's just, that's just the truth.
True infrared therapy light, you know, it's going to be $5,000, $6,000.
An infrared therapy, the positive of that is that you get this deep heat.
And that's where you end up with, it's basically a hyperthermia, wherever you put that infrared.
And one of the ways that you'll know that it's a better infrared device, not just the cost, is that there will be no light.
So, in true infrared, does not produce light.
I would not say it a red light therapy that claims to have infrared light.
It doesn't have benefits, light therapy has benefits, but it's not going to go deep and it's not going to produce deep heat.
So, there's a lot of companies that use false data, or maybe I should say, that steal research from, that's out there that's not based upon their device.
And you see that in like the PMF industry.
The research on PMF devices is, is all on high Gauss PMF devices.
And then companies that sell a PMF device that's a very low Gauss uses that same research to say that this is what PMF does, PMF does.
And the truth is, that's not what your PMF will do because you have a machine that produces 700 Gauss.
The research was done on a machine that produces 30,000 Gauss.
So, you're just going to be careful with claims that are made by different companies.
But there certainly can be no harm done.
You just got to be careful with what machines you spend money on.
Next question.
Dr. Cutters, I emailed you pictures of what I believe to be a piece of the tumor that I coughed out.
I'm wondering if it's possible to cough or pass tumors as a response to alternative treatments.
The answer is yes, it's very possible to cough out tissue or pass tissue in the case of colon cancer or rectal cancer.
It is cancerous.
This has happened multiple times in the past.
I've even had patients bring it in to get tested.
But that's the only way you would absolutely know for sure is to bring it in a path lab and have a test in whether there's cancer cells in that.
Do we know?
Does it matter?
Well, yes, no, you're trying to get rid of the cancer that said you're lungs.
If you cough something out and there's distinct blob that looks very different.
I've never had this happen before.
Could this be tumor?
The only way to know for sure is to get a pathology report on that.
Whether your path lab would do that, whether your oncologist would play a part of that or not.
I don't know.
But that would be the only way to know for sure.
So that's not always doable.
But is it possible?
That's the question.
The answer is yes, it's very possible.
So hopefully that's is what happened.
Next question.
I put this in small font.
Excuse me.
Do you have any experience with.
Minigilma.
So,
Minigilma is a tumor on the midages.
That's a part of the brain.
The.
The cases.
The nerves and brain itself.
I was wondering if there's a holistic treatment that restores the secretion of Merlin enzyme.
And that suppresses tumor growth.
So with Minigilma, there is a.
So with the different tumors, with the different nerve tumors, there's a gene called the NF2 gene.
That is neurofibroma factor two or something like that.
Because there were neurofibromas there.
That's a common disorder that is genetic where a person will get these lumps all over.
And these are fibrous tumors that are benign and typically stay benign.
But they,
but it's genetic and it can be embarrassing.
It's just it's not, you know, doesn't look good.
You can get them on your face and it's unpleasant.
Well, they found that it's a, a defect in this gene and it's a tumor suppressor gene.
So they called it neurofibroma two, I think.
And it's a tumor suppressor gene and the tumor suppressor gene makes an enzyme which is called Merlin.
And that Merlin enzyme then helps silence tumor growth.
So the purpose of tumor suppressor genes is that let's say if I have a cancer that starts in a cell.
So get cancer starts with just one cell.
It's a healthy, it's a normal cell that is damaged.
So something gets inside that cell, whether it's a toxin or a biotoxin of some sort that damages the nucleus so that it starts a reproductive phase.
And so that starts to rapidly reproduce.
Well, then it kicks on these tumor suppressor genes.
This is why everybody doesn't have cancer.
So these tumor suppressor genes kick on and they produce enzymes that stimulate intrinsic apoptotic cycle.
So they stimulate the death of the cell from the inside.
So apoptosis is normal programs sell death.
And that's what you want to stimulate.
So that's what a tumor suppressor gene basically turns on is this intrinsic apoptosis.
So the cancer cell dies.
And then you never know you had cancer.
So the truth is is that everybody has cancer all the time, but your body is fighting it and destroyed it largely due to these tumor suppressor genes.
And if I have genetic defects in these tumor suppressor genes, then I'm not causing this intrinsic apoptotic response.
I'm getting a less intrinsic apoptotic response.
So I have a greater chance at this continues to reproduce, whether it's a tumor or whether it's a malignant cancer.
Now, with NF2 defects, you could get neurofibromatosis, but you could also get other brain tumors admitted.
Geomas are one of those things.
So honestly, I haven't really researched what would be the nutritional intervention for someone with NF2 defects.
But I will say in general, with so many of the other tumor suppressor genes, if a person has defects in those tumor suppressor genes, one major component that can be an intervention would be a curcumin.
So curcumin or tumor that can help has been proven to help those with P53 gene defects, which is another tumor suppressor genes with bronca gene defects, also resveratrol and great T extract can help with those.
And I think that the mechanism of action on that is that it decreases IL-6 and decreases the expression of m-tore.
So m-tore is a whole other discussion, and I actually have some videos on m-tore.
I do know that that Merlin and the tumor suppressor gene that's associated with it does tie to m-tore as well and lack thereof production of Merlin increases m-tore function.
And go to, let's see, I mentioned if you go to cuttersclinic.com and you search for m-tore m capital small m capital TOR.
You'll see that pathway and then you'll see some videos I created.
If it's not on cuttersclinic.com, if you go to our YouTube channel or our videos dot cuttersclinic.com and you search for m-tore, you'll see some videos I created on that.
The m-tore pathway is essential to understand if you have tumors or cancer because what you want to do is to suppress that m-tore pathway.
Now some of the things that, again, how would you deal with this? Some of the things that stimulate the m-tore pathway even more are listed in that video.
So I would think from a dietary standpoint, things like dairy stimulate the m-tore pathway. That's why it's good for most cancer patients to be off of dairy because it has growth factors in it.
Things that will increase IGF-1 levels, things that will increase estrogen levels and imbalances and hormones.
So if you look through that, I think you'll find the best information on that.
Okay, some other questions came in. Good days, sir. I have constant pain in the balls of my feet.
I don't know so many therapy blood tests.
Hard to understand that question. Ealing pain, I think. I live in Holland.
Okay, so you could help reformulate that question and submit that again. I would appreciate that.
Toddler having filed diarrhea today after eating sand yesterday. What can I do to support the digestion through this?
Sometimes the best thing you can do, honestly, is to let it pass.
I'd be more concerned if your toddler ate sand and then they were constipated than you'd want to do things to help remove that.
Sometimes when you understand if you get sick and you are vomiting, sometimes the way that we have been taught through the medical system is that we got to stop this vomiting.
So we're going to give this person a Tylenol. We're going to give this person, you know, to decrease the fever. My child has a fever.
So I'm going to give him Tylenol to decrease the fever. Yes, I've decreased the fever. I've solved the problem.
Actually, you probably made the problem much worse. The body caused this increase fever state to go off an infection.
The body is causing you to expel your stomach contents to deal with an infection.
So you're expeling your stomach contents. Now, of course, there's limits to how high the fever you want to get and there's limits to a person, you know, having just explosive vomiting that is uncontrollable.
Same thing with diarrhea. You have to get to the root of things, right?
But same thing with diarrhea. The person's got diarrhea and you can pinpoint it to the AIDS sand. Maybe it was, you know, it was just the irritation of the sand, the silica or whatever that's in that sand or the rocks that's in there that they're expeling that it's a good thing that they're expeling that so
If you could, if you could, if we could all start to think that way, a little better of why the body is doing this.
It could give us more clues to, you know, what's going on and it could give us more clues to maybe this is a good thing that's going on. You should just let it go on.
That can, that can be even better. Have you heard how to treat birdie mouth by mother has that. So birdie mouth is actually a syndrome.
I'd have to look that up again. Actually, somebody had that question a few months ago.
And quite as I can't remember. I did research that I can't remember what that was tied to. I apologize. I could look that up and hopefully answer that next week for you.
One of the things you'll find about me is I'm not going to.
Below me through an answer that I don't know. So I got somebody asked that. Maybe it was on our other Zoom call.
It was probably a year ago or something like that. I did look that up, but I'll have to look that up again and see so I can answer that next time.
Some other questions that came in on the holistic health oversight. Do you recommend doing parasite protocols regularly, whether you have symptoms or not.
And if so, how often is it beneficial to let the body rest and recuperate after a certain amount of time.
If there are symptoms of diopts once you are doing a parasite cleanse. Is there a particular type of protocol that you would recommend herbal parasite supplements or parasite medications?
There's a lot of questions there. Do you want to recommend doing a parasite cleanse on a regular basis?
Yeah, I do. I personally do. But remember, there's different types of parasites. So there's intestinal parasites. There's there's parasites that could go systemic.
There's parasites that are not truly parasites, but their bacteria that are basically parasitic.
And so they need to be treated a little bit differently. Personally, I use our private label product called ParaClear because it has things in there that will help with intestinal parasites and worms and things in there that will help with bacteria, bacterial type parasitic things like H. Pyloric, which is a bacterial infection.
But kind of acts like a parasite because it can be very long term that you could have it for years and spread it like crazy and just get it back again and it could cause a whole lot of ill health.
That's why I like ParaClear because it has the things in there that will help with that.
So there are other parasite programs out there. We have some products from CellCore. They have a parasite protocol bundle with different herbs in it in each supplement. And you take these three or four supplements.
And you go through a month of this and that could be a nice cleanse.
The reason why I personally like the ParaClear is because there's a go, you have to take more, if it takes same amount of pills, they're all in one bottle.
So you're getting it all in one bottle. You might, if you feel like you have parasites, like when I take ParaClear, I've had a fact that I just did this with my wife just last week for about a week.
I took anywhere between nine and 12 capsules a day. I only did it for like three or four days. I think I skipped a day.
Because I'm not very good at taking something, but sometimes I forgot, I got busy. But I think it really does help clear any parasites, any bacteria. And I always have the fear of Hpilora when you are the understanding.
Hpilora, I think you should treat it on a regular basis. Do we let you know three or four days, once three month, I think is extremely beneficial.
Second part of this question should you use a bite would you have to worry about die offs when you're doing a parasite cleanse.
If you're doing a parasite cleanse that's dealing with parasites that are in your gut or in your liver, like liver flukes, no, you don't really have to worry about die offs at all. You're going to expel that.
Again, you've got to make sure you're all your phases of detoxification are open. If you're constipated, you're only having available every three days, you've got to deal with that before you think about doing a parasite cleanse.
But if you're moving your balls, at least once, twice a day, no, you shouldn't have any issue with die offs. If you feel like you're getting, if you, if you do a parasite cleanse, like using a product, like ParaClear that has burberry in it and garlic in it, and you're getting herximer type reactions, then you need to, you need to rethink what you possibly have going on.
The only thing that's going to truly give you a herximer type reaction is if you're dealing with a gram negative bacteria, because they have lipo polysaccharides in their cell membrane, when they die, that's going to stimulate it in response, you're going to feel yucky because you're just producing too many endotoxins.
And that is in the blood that's not in the gut.
So using a binder can be helpful, no matter what you're dealing with.
So adding a binder to your protocol, taking that out of empty stomach can be helpful. But if you're starting to get herximer reactions, you need to rethink really what it is that you could be killing with that.
Or if you have to be careful while you're doing something like that too, if you're taking something with garlic in it, which is something that you'd use typically for H. Pylori and for parasites, that's going to be an immune stimulant.
And you do have to be aware of that if you have, if you know you have an autoimmune disease, that's why I think if you know you have an autoimmune disease, let's say if you have Hashimoto's.
You think you have parasites doing the short term parasite cleanse like three or four days out of the month are actually much healthier for you.
If you do a month long parasite protocol that has immune stimulants in it, and you already know you have an autoimmune disease like you already were diagnosed with thyroid antibodies.
So you have Hashimoto's you're going to make your thyroid worse during that time. So I wouldn't do that. So remember if you're going to stimulate your immune system, you want to do it for a short period of time.
If you have auto antibody antibodies to self tissue, because you will kill that which you have antibodies against first, which is your thyroid gland in this instance, so be careful of that.
That's question came in line with chat. Do you suggest any natural way to address a fib currently on medication, but would like to consider a natural supplement under professional healthcare provider.
So again, you want to look for what could be the cause. So a fib has to do with multiple different possible causes. The simplest cause of a fib can be a deficiency and vitamin D.
And issues with vitamin D receptors, you could have genetic issues, vitamin D receptors, and those people tend to be tend to take vitamin D and can get their blood vitamin D levels up.
And it imbalance in vitamin D affects the calcium channels in the in the endothelial layer affects the blood pressure and affects the cytoside atrial node and can cause a fib.
So years ago, I remember one of my patients years ago, said her mom was an a fib and they were going to panel her. She was completely awake and they didn't want to do that.
I discussed this with her. She brought a bottle of liquid dropper vitamin D in gave her 30,000 I use a vitamin D took her out of a fib immediately.
Now, I'd say that works with everybody, but that is the simplest solution to it if that is the issue. So getting to the issue of a fib.
Other issues with a fib are inflammation in the brain itself. So the mid brain is where you have control over that.
The issues with the essay node and inflammation in the mid brain can cause a chronic a fib issue.
How would you know that? Well, there's a video. If you go back to cuttersclinic.com and you search in the search, they search neuro inflammation neuro and you are, oh, inflammation, I created a video on that it's a half hour video highly suggest you take a half hour of your day and watch that.
There is a phenomena that is quite common with people that have there's multiple different sources of neuro inflammation and brain inflammation and many times most time people don't know that they have it. They just have other symptoms and have been given labels of other diseases or syndromes and it's stepping from neuro inflammation.
So have to look at causes of neuro inflammation and how to treat it.
Well, but I'm going to call microglial primary that go into that into detail. And then a further is to be tested for neural antibodies, which would be a sidrix array seven X test.
If you have neural antibodies and or to a lesser you have microglial in private neural inflammation cause all sorts of problems and a fib is just one of the possibilities.
Alright, next question came in on the chat button. The holistic health oversight my mom has taken back drum and turns out she's allergic to it. The last dose of back drum was week and a half ago she's still experiencing a 10 symptoms and she's been in the hospital twice any recommendations how to get this out of her system.
It's on a probiotic to help her got now. Yeah, it's hard when you have an allergic reaction to a medication because the allergic reaction to the medication can can legal for a long time and part of the reason it can linger for a long time is because you might have actually.
So let's take a step back a lot of people will go we need to detox that medication we're going to support detoxification pathways and try to get that medication out of the system.
It could be lingering in the tissues it could be still causing problems that can be true.
But why do some people after a medication or or some source of exposure to something seemingly continue to have symptoms long periods of time afterwards.
The answer to that really lies in the what that allergic reaction to that medication did to the person.
The truth is there may be nothing more to detoxify that may be gone.
If they're there may not even be a way to find out but if there was a way to find out that that product might not be in the person symptom in the person's system anymore.
They still may have any problems because it stimulated a reaction it stimulated in a flammatory reaction in that inflammatory reaction just up tick that person's.
Current issue that they had that was that was lying dormant in a perfect example of that is what I was just discussing a few minutes ago with neuro inflammation.
If you have micro glial set prime micro glial cells in the brain and of course this is gibberish unless you watch that video so go to colors clinic.com search for neuro inflammation watch the 30 minute video I explained micro glial cells.
What they are in the brain they're the brains immune system if they become damaged they can become damaged from a myriad of different reasons.
And you can have basically not an idea that that has taken place because you have credited your symptoms to other things you have other diseases you have other problems.
But it can be stepping from micro glial primate and so if you have prime micro glial cells anything can trigger prime micro glial cells to go into this state that's called this inflamed state this M1 state.
So they stay in this inflamed state and they're just spewing out inflammatory cytokines.
When they're doing that depending on where these micro glial cells are in your brain they can affect you in all sorts of different ways if they're the pridal pridal lobes of the brain they're going to affect your sensory nervous system so they can cause pain and inflammation in various parts of the body.
If they're in your motor cortex they're going to cause motor issues you're going to have issues with function issues with muscle function issues with coordination.
They're in your cerebellum you're going to make your coordination issue if they're in your prefrontal cortex you're going to have thought process and cloudy thinking it and so depending on where you remember your brain controls everything right so if you have inflammation.
You know areas that are in your brain that are spewing out inflammatory cytokines you could have just a mere a different type of symptoms highly suggest you look at that because there's ways to calm that down so it may not be that you have to detox the poison anymore it's what the poison did to your body that you have to calm down.
So there's in that video I list you know taking flavonoids and be careful with with exercise and zero alcohol and some general detoxification support and stimulating parasympathetic nervous system so there's all sorts of different recommendations that I go through on that so just understand anything can trigger that.
So you know you could be living a fairly healthy life and you know you you pay your head you know and now your life is just completely changed you know so this is this is where you know lots of times people come to us so they say my life changed completely when this happened.
When I took this medic had a reaction when I had a car accident had a concussion my life has never been to change never been to say you have to think this person has microglial primate or worse this person has auto antibodies to neural tissue we need to find the triggers calm it down we need to calm down that inflammation and get to the source of this.
That that would be my biggest recommendation trying to get to the source of what's really causing the problem.
Next question I saw a video of your saying that most cancer patients shouldn't eat dairy is that for all cancer patients can we still eat butter well.
Yes, no so most cancer patients should need dairy why is that so big I alluded to it the first question of this call is that dairy stimulates a pathway in your body called mTOR so this mTOR pathway if it's up regulated is going to increase replication rates.
And dairy increases mTOR because dairy has growth factor so anything that's going to increase growth you have to be aware of with with cancer so dairy isn't the only thing that increases growth there's certain nutrients that increase growth like copper.
So a lot of times we'll see cancer patients committed they're taking a multivitamin with copper will copper increases growth it cancer patients should be on copper.
I'm going back to that one question that I had about the NF2 gene about admitted geoma another thing I should mention of that the effort that I just thought of right now is when you have defects on tumor suppressor genes.
You have to be more careful of another nutritional product not to be taking it so I don't think any cancer patients or I think the state of different way I think every cancer patient should be careful of their supplements that they're taking I don't think they should be taking in general I don't think cancer patients be taking copper and in general I don't think cancer patients should be taking methyl groups.
So what are methyl groups so methyl groups are supplements that have a methyl group of C with three H's what is that where would you get that in methyl cobalamine so if you're B12 supplement so where would you get methyl cobalamine if you're taking it just a B12 supplement look at the back of it as it's a methyl cobalamine if you have cancer I don't think you should be taking that.
If you have a supplement that's methyl folate I don't think you should be taking that either in lots of times you'll get it in a multiple in a multiple multiple vitamin so multiple B complex it'll be methyl cobalamine or methyl folate or L5 methyl tetrahedral folate that's a little bit listed on the back why should you avoid that why does it tie to tumor suppressor genes.
Because methyl groups what are the benefits in their bodies they help silence genes they help turn genes off well if you know you have cancer or you have tumors and they are tied to tumor suppressor gene defects possibly
methyl groups will silence also silence tumor suppressor genes so they'll turn off tumor suppressor genes and remember what I said if you're with me a few minutes ago is your best way to fight cancer internally cellular eternally is that when cell you know you get something inside of a cell you know a toxin or something if it inadvertently damages the DNA.
The DNA starts to rapidly reproduce it'll stimulate your tumor suppressor genes what your tumor suppressor genes do is they basically cause the internal from the inside out destruction of the cell so they stimulate the intrinsic apoptotic capsaic pathways as they help the cell die so that you'd ever get a diagnosis of cancer well if you're taking a ton of methyl groups you can silence those genes you can turn them off.
So I'm not a fan of that I'm also not a fan of just you know a lot of people practitioners that do genetic testing will look at your MTHRG to go oh you have a defect on 1298 or you have a double allele defect on 677 so we're going to we have to put you on methyl folate and we have to put you on methyl comolamine that's just that's just not good practice.
Now even if you have a double allele defect on both 677 and 1298 see you you have to look at everything else if you have other if you have defects in your bioptera pathway on your serotonin genes and you use ethyl excess methyl groups you're going to stimulate excess production of serotonin which is not good it's going to affect you emotionally it's going to cause rage and anger issues and all sorts of things you have to take a
30,000 view you know for view of your genetics when you do genetic workup not just you don't just treat a gene defect it's certainly if you have cancer you have to be more careful of that.
The only exception of that you could you have to look at the patient holistically a person who was seeing issues you might have to give a methyl group syrup here at the time so I give you it's it's not just one thing but certainly if a person has a disorder where they're producing minigiomas or you know fibromas of some kind and it's because of a gene a tumor suppressor gene defect you have to be a
more careful if you have a cancer diagnosis you have to be more careful of methyl groups look forward to your weekly health hour learn so much why thank you hopefully you're learning and I'm not doing this in vain so I'm glad you are thankful.
Okay next question there are a lot of Instagram and Facebook videos and posts that claim this or that nutrient cures cancer what do you have to say about this?
I'd say be very very careful so I'm not afraid of that I just do not like alternative practitioners they might have the best part excuse me in the world and they're trying to help cancer patients you know immensely they're trying to give the best advice but everybody is unique.
And to say oh this cures cancer I've seen Facebook posts like that where people make up make create really pretty memes that say it tumor kills cancer in 100% or some silly thing like that well the truth is if you took a petri dish and you put cancer cells in there you could put evaporated water in with it it would probably kill the cancer cells so it doesn't mean
evaporated water kills cancer cells or some silly things like that it's just to me it's just foolishness everybody's physiology is different you got to look at the big picture you got to treat people individually and I think it gives alternative practitioners a black eye honestly when you see claims like that or when you see quote-a-quote nutritionists make certain claims that that are just not
completely honest and I think that's there's danger in that I think it gives people you know wrong thoughts about what's going to help deal with their cancer or their serious disease I see a lot of Instagram posts like that and it's I just unfollow those people because it's just I think they influence people the wrong way especially we live in this world of influencers right
we're going to be careful who you are allowing to influence you the Bible is very clear that we're supposed to be careful that we protect our mind so that we don't allow you know bad influencers who all sorts of that going on so you have to be careful with that so no I don't say there's not validity in anything but when you start making claims then you do you do have to be careful
I also have a struggle when you hear claims and I just talked to somebody the other day that they said they're starting to drink alkaline water because doctors so and so said that alkaline water is the best thing oh my word it's like I'm talked about this in the past lots of times
that's just not the right thing to do please don't do that you're not alkalizing your system when you are drinking alkaline water you're not alkalizing your system doing anything from an oral standpoint so it's just it's just really poor understanding of physiology
and that just makes me really sad
okay last question is a rife machine the best way to kill cancer I can't remember if I had this on last week or not
I would say the rife machine doesn't kill cancer yet again yet to be careful about any claims that you're making I think a rife machine properly programmed properly working with the right frequencies for that person
that has cancer can help your immune system kill the cancer but I don't think the rife machine directly destroys cancer or kills cancer even though I think anyone with cancer should be adding everybody with cancer should be using a rife machine I don't think I'd be talking to you right now I didn't use a rife machine or my cancer
and I will stand by that tell my dad I really think that's you know besides the grace of God I think God led me you know to be able to program it right for me and to to get the benefits from it but I also say that it doesn't it's not it's not a magic one and it works in conjunction with the person's immune system and other things that you're doing so
all those things together are the best way to help deal with cancer you've got to take a big picture view of everybody because again everybody is unique so
all right well thank you for being with us again on this holistic health hour remind you to go to holistic health hour dot com where we have all our past shows
videos and we have really nice little narrative that goes with it so you can see where what video you might want to watch and the questions that were asked of that
also a reminder go to cutters clinic dot com highly recommend our courses we got a distilled deal prices because I just literally want to get people help get the information out there so start working through the courses and
and you're going to learn a ton I know you'll have a lot of aha moments on cutters clinic dot com you can also search our blogs for any other question you have all right God bless go to holistic health hour if you want to ask questions
for next week post those questions so we can get them on for sure all right bye bye.